Next we're going to prove that
the transformation just described
does in fact reduce 3-CNF
satisfiability to independent set.
We start by arguing that
if f is satisfiable
then the output graph G has
an independent set of size m.
We'll let t be a satisfying
assignment for f.
In our example, let's take the one
that makes a true, b false, c false,
and d false, and
we'll set the complements accordingly.
Then, we choose one literal from
each clause in our original formula
that is true under the truth assignment,
and this will form our set S.
So in our example, I might choose this
a, this b bar and this b bar here.
Clearly the size of this set is m,
the number of clauses.
Because the vertices come
from distinct clauses,
there can't be any within clause edges
and because the truth assignment t
doesn't contradict itself,
there can't be any contradiction or
between clause edges either,
therefore S must be an independent set.
And indeed it is in this example.
Let's prove the other direction next.
If G has an independent set of size m,
then the formula f, is satisfiable.
We start with an independent
set of size m in the graph.
Here I've marked an independent
set in our example graph.
The fact that there can be
no between-clause edges in S
implies that the literals in
S come from distinct clauses.
And the fact that there
are no between-clause edges
implies that the literals
in S are non-contradictory.
Therefore any assignment
consistent with the literals of S
will satisfy the original formula f.
Here the choice of literals a, b and
c implies that a, b and c all be true.
We can set d however we like,
true or false, and
we still have a satisfying assignment.
So that completes the proof that
independent set is as hard as 3-CNF.
And that completes this chain here,
showing that both independent set and
Vertex Cover are NP-Complete.
Now we're going to branch out,
both in the tree here and
in the type of arguments we'll make,
by considering the Subset Sum problem.